Yo!
Hi. Thanks
for meeting me here.
This is your high school?
- This is my high school.
- What, uh--
Murry Bergtraum High School
for Business Careers.
As you can see,
we're directly next to--
- Across from the Tombs.
- Yeah, surrounded
by One Police Plaza.
So, Bergtraum is viewed
as one of the worst schools
in the city.
Like, I had to kind of join
an elite group within this
high school to stay afloat.
I just felt like
most of the time,
I was trying to survive.
Our meritocracy,
because it's based
on competition,
worships superiority
rather than excellence.
Certain people get to start
way farther ahead.
Fabiola: I feel like for so much
of my education and childhood,
it was just like,
studying hard for tests
specifically to prove
that I'm good enough
through tests.
Education is supposed
to be an equalizer.
It is built
on the meritocratic belief
that effort and ability
are the keys to success.
But is that really all it takes
to be successful in school?
What about opportunity
and access?
This false notion
of a meritocracy
has furthered the interests
of those of great wealth
in this country
and those of
great political power.
So, why are we here?
I'm on a quest to figure out
why the meritocratic beliefs
that the American dream
is built on
don't really work
for people who look like us.
And so I want to figure out
how we got here
and what we will do about it.
( theme music playing )
"Halls of hell at New York's
worst high school."
This is a headline
about my high school,
published in March 2012.
This headline is super dramatic.
- Just a little dramatic.
- ( Fabiola chuckles )
How did you end up
at Murry Bergtraum
in the first place?
So, I had a pretty high
GPA in middle school.
It was a selective middle school
that I had to test to get into.
Uh, but in New York City,
you basically rank
what high schools
you'd be interested in going to,
and not a single school
selected me.
I got a call instead from,
like, the Department of Ed
saying, "Hey, you gotta go
to second round."
And that's something
you don't want to do,
'cause second round,
what they did was
they handed you a list
of high schools and said,
"These are the places
that have room."
And when you look at that list,
it's basically a list of schools
that were considered
failing schools,
schools that were
plagued by violence,
just under-resourced.
And so I looked
at the list and was like,
"I'm gonna make a choice based
off of what's less bad."
That's crazy, though.
That's, like, med school.
- It's-- it's bad.
- You shouldn't have
to match for high school.
- Yeah, it's bad.
- Christophe: Or middle school.
I mean, the idea of
in elementary school
having to test into
a competitive middle school
- was completely not
on my radar at the time.
- Fabiola: Exactly.
So, the reason
why I have you here today
is because
I'm exploring this question
is meritocracy a myth?
Here we have a game
called Rigged,
and I think this
can help us illustrate
whether it's just
ability and effort
that allows you
to get successful.
The object of the game is to get
to Glad You Asked University.
Look how beautiful that is.
There are two different sides
to the board game.
So, we have Pleasantville
on that end
and then we have
Smallville over here.
So, I'm going to
have you pull a card
to determine essentially
what your fate is.
- Are you guys ready to play?
- I'm ready.
All right.
My card says, "Home.
You come from a two-parent
middle class household.
Action: Move two steps
forward at Pleasantville."
"Your mom
is a food service worker
and your dad is cab driver.
Go start at Smallville."
"You come from
a low-income household,
and I start from
the start at Smallville."
Both of my parents
are lawyers,
and guess how far
I get to move on this path.
I get to move five steps
forward at Pleasantville.
One, two, three, four, five.
"You've been selected
for the honor roll.
Advance three steps."
- So, you got an opportunity.
- Opportunity!
"You have won a scholarship
for being athlete of the year."
- You gotta be kidding me.
- ( laughter )
"You did not go to pre-K.
Pay $15,000 and skip a turn."
Bill de Blasio, where you at?
I'm already almost cooked.
"Serendipity.
Your teacher recommends you
for a gifted and talented
program that you test into.
Collect $10,000."
"You inherit $40,000
from your distant uncle.
Take the next ladder."
Oh, my God.
I'm enjoying this ride.
I can tell who
designed this game.
"Your big brother was shot."
- Whoa.
- Wow. Jesus.
"You miss two weeks
of school for bereavement.
Pay the bank $10,000."
- Jeez.
- That's intense.
- Yeah.
- "You can't do your homework
because the wifi is out.
Pay $5,000."
- That's hard.
- I have done stories on that.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
"You start to doubt
your abilities
as a student
in middle school
so you begin to act out.
Take the next detour."
- So, you just gotta--
- Nothing's working out.
You know, I mean,
this is what happens
when you're watching
your kid siblings at night
and your mom's missing work.
- And you're tired when you
get to school, you know?
- Yeah.
I mean, you talk back
to your teachers,
and then you can't escape
ol' Smallville.
- All right.
- Fabiola's about to win.
- She really is.
- Two steps. Wow!
I think you guys
need to clap for me.
Thank you so much.
So, is this game fair?
- Do you think this was fair?
- Obviously not.
- Why not?
- Because we lost.
- ( laughter )
Clearly. Uh, no.
I mean, just by the fact
that certain people get
to start way farther ahead
means that it can't be fair.
Our positions are also exactly
following our family wealth.
You can't escape
your neighborhood, like,
no matter what you do.
The odds are just
stacked against you.
This is incredibly frustrating.
So, my question is
why is America so
obsessed with merit?
Why is it such a huge part
of our country's fabric?
The concept of a meritocracy
goes back centuries.
However, it took off
in America in the 1950s
due to dissatisfaction
with an inept
yet excessively wealthy
aristocracy.
In a quest
to diversity the elite
and increase social mobility
for the working class,
a group of reformers
came together and decided
that society must offer
enough opportunity
for talent to combine
with effort
so that anyone
could rise to the top.
However, 1950s America
was consumed by racism
and segregation.
Black and Native American
children were not taught
with white children,
often had less access
to resources,
and were schooled
in sub-standard buildings.
Nevertheless,
the term meritocracy took hold,
and society embraced merit
as the key way to unlocking
the American dream.
So, what is your reaction
just off the bat?
You know, if you have
a connection
between race and class,
let's say,
and you exacerbate
economic inequality,
you're gonna harm
people of color,
even if you also benefit
some people of color
whom you admit.
Unless you're either
super talented or super lucky,
if you're outside of the elite,
probably hard work
is not gonna be enough.
The new meritocrats,
who had themselves
gotten ahead
by being good in school
and good at tests,
had an almost unlimited appetite
for educating their children
and incredible
capacity to do so.
And so today's meritocrats,
they spend resources
on training their kids
that nobody else
in society can match.
If you go to the average
public school in America today,
probably about $12,000
to $15,000 a year
is spent on educating you
per child.
If you go to one of the "Forbes"
top 20 private schools,
probably about $75,000
is spent per child
per year on educating kids.
And so it's not just
poor people who can't keep up
with today's elite.
- It's the middle class.
- As part of this journey,
I've been trying to understand
why we rely on tests so much
and what they're
actually measuring.
Our meritocracy,
because it's based
on competition,
worships superiority
rather than excellence.
And so the way
in which they measure
people's whatever,
"merit," is not neutral,
particularly as between
white people and black people.
If you have resources
to hire people whose job it is
to teach your kids
how to do well at the tests,
you know, they're gonna do
really well at the test.
So it's not just a matter
of outputs, but also inputs.
What chances did you have,
and importantly,
will society commit
to giving everybody
meaningful opportunity?
How many tests
do you think the average
American kid takes
between grades K through 12?
Well, I have a terrible memory,
but it makes sense to me
that we probably took
maybe two a year.
So, from pre-K to senior year,
it would've been 28?
Ooh. Okay, good guess.
But I regret to say
that it is not that.
It's actually 112.
- No way.
- Yeah.
Test-taking
is a specific skill
- that is not like anything
else we do in our lives.
- Yeah.
And I really question
how much it transfers
to actual, like,
things you need to
succeed as an adult.
So, I want to explore
the tests that
we took growing up.
I feel like this one
gets overlooked
because it's not mandatory.
But G&T, gifted and talented,
are you familiar with that?
I am. Yeah. I mean,
we didn't call it that
in Arizona, though.
We had a program
in elementary school
called Project Potential.
These names are so--
as I'm older, thinking about
these names, I'm like,
they weren't trying to hide
what their motives were.
- No. Yeah.
- Like, "This is what it is."
The teacher would refer
certain students for testing,
which in retrospect
gives a lot of power
to that teacher.
Fabiola:
You're right.
A 2016 study
found that a teacher's race
and racial bias
consistently affected
how they interpreted
their students' behaviors
or abilities
and who they would recommend
for a gifted program.
Additionally, black students
are more likely
than their white peers
to receive suspensions,
be excluded
for greater periods of time,
and be disciplined
for less serious offenses.
And we see the same kind of bias
in testing with the SHSAT.
In New York City,
the SHSAT was the test
that you had to take
in order to get into
a specialized high school.
If you can't pass this test,
sorry, you can't, like,
go to one of these top schools.
So, Stuyvesant, New York City's
most selective public school,
in 2019, out of a class
of almost 900 students,
only seven black kids got in.
In 2019, the New York City
Independent Budget Office
simulated what offers
to the incoming 9th grade class
would've looked like
if admissions were based
on students' ranking
in the top seven percent
of their middle school
instead of their ranking
on the SHSAT.
The report found that
about 19% of admissions offers
would have gone
to black students,
and about 27 would have
gone to Hispanic students,
compared to the actual 4%
and 6% respectively.
It seems like testing doesn't
happen in a bubble, right?
It depends on how much money
your parents have.
It depends on where you live.
All of these things impact
what kinds of resources
you're able to access inside
and outside of the classroom.
I think the one that
hasn't really entered our
conversation yet is the SAT.
Joss:
Ah, yes.
Yeah, did you know that
the SAT was founded by a guy
who supported
the eugenics movement?
- No. That's deeply disturbing.
- Yeah, it's very disturbing.
This is data straight
from College Board,
which administers the SAT.
In 2015, 1.7 million students
sat for the SAT.
What stands out
probably the most is
for black test-takers,
we see the lowest scores
across the board,
and the lowest in writing.
And it's not just how well
you prepare for this one test,
but how well your
entire education has
prepared you for it,
and we know that
the schools are not equal.
For me,
I was fortunate enough
through a program
called Legal Outreach
to take an entire summer
of SAT prep course.
Reflecting on
that opportunity,
I was like,
"Wow, I had to apply, again,
to get into that program."
I may have a 95 GPA,
but these programs
kind of helped me
understand how to play
the game of the system.
So, how was the test for you?
The test? I actually--
I think because of the prep,
I enjoyed taking the SAT.
- With reading and writing,
like, I did really well.
- You're a full nerd.
- Yeah, I'm just, like,
into that kind of thing.
- You enjoy testing.
There is one specific story
that I want to get into
that I think helped shape
my idea of ability
and what it means to feel
special through the system.
My sister Grace,
who's two years older than me,
got into a program
in New York City
called Prep for Prep.
That program
basically identifies
the high-achieving,
low-income students
across the city
and says, "We want to help
train these students
by giving them extra
course work to prepare them
for some of the best
private schools in America."
So, Grace ended up
going to Exeter,
then got into Princeton.
This is her Princeton diploma.
Thank you, Grace,
for letting me have
this here today.
My sister and I did very well.
We are low-income kids,
grew up in Brooklyn, New York,
and clearly meritocracy to
some extent has worked for us
because we were able
to take advantage
of opportunities
like Prep for Prep,
like Legal Outreach,
like the Posse Foundation,
which by the way
gave me a full tuition
scholarship to Dickenson.
But I'm conflicted because
I'm the exception.
Like, should I be up here
talking about this?
Should I be talking
about my sister when
we are the exceptions?
I wish that there
were a way to actually
level the playing field
so that everyone gets help,
everyone gets opportunity.
- Fabiola: Hey, sis.
- Hey, sister.
- What's going on?
- Nothing much.
Just calling you as I work
through this episode.
Thank you again for letting
me use your diplomas.
As I'm working on this episode,
I'm conflicted, right?
Because it's worked out for us.
It's helped a lot of people
in our family,
but at the same time,
meritocracy has kept
a lot of people back.
Poor people,
black and brown people,
they're still
not getting ahead.
Yeah, that's something
I think about as well.
Our accomplishments
are definitely celebrated,
but at the same time,
they're weaponized
and used against
people who look like us
to pretty much say,
"If they can do it,
why can't you do the same?
But they're forgetting
the fact that ultimately
we always just had to do
way more with a lot less.
So, there's actually
an organization,
they're called
the Brotherhood/Sister Sol,
and they've been working
to level the playing field.
They've been giving students
more opportunities
because they realize
that it's just not fair,
so I want to try
and talk to them.
I'm gonna reach out and see
if they can help me
wrap my mind around this.
Cool, cool.
Let me know how it goes, sis.
I will, thank you. Bye.
Man: You see our college
pendants up on the ceiling,
which is the universities
and colleges where our
young people are studying.
And, you know,
it inspires the next generation
that comes in to see,
you know,
what are opportunities.
We take them on
college tours as well,
but this is
just a daily reminder.
And are the students bringing
these back themselves?
Yeah, they're always proud,
especially if they're
the first to go to a school,
to put it up.
Fabiola: Okay.
Previously, we were
looking at SAT results
and we saw
that black students
did not as well
as their white
and Asian counterparts.
What's your response to that,
and also would you
call that an achievement gap?
I think there's a fundamental
access gap in the country.
It's not an achievement gap.
You can't have a country
that has 13 generations
of slavery,
when it was illegal
to read and write,
four generations
of segregation,
when the system
was by law unequal,
and two generations
of legal freedom,
and expect
the playing field to be equal.
Until we create
a true equal playing field,
you will not have
equal achievement.
And we have to look
at access and opportunity.
Those are the key
inflection points,
and I think that's what
we have to talk about
if we really want
an equitable society.
When I was in eighth grade,
I entered a program
called Legal Outreach.
But I had to, like,
show what my grades were,
and you couldn't have
below a certain average
to be in the program.
Can you talk about
this idea of cherry-picking,
and do you have the same
kind of philosophy at Bro/Sis?
We do no sifting here.
What we mean by that
is you can have any
grade point average
and join the organization.
I think the role of education
should be focused
on the development
of the whole child.
It's really
about wraparound support
for young people
so that they are supported
and guided and loved,
but that they also have
opportunities and access
so that they can develop
their own agency in life.
In thinking about
the public school system
right now in New York City,
what is it gonna take
to make it a real meritocracy?
New York City
has a public school system
that is a caste system,
where you have elite schools,
good schools,
mediocre schools,
and horrible schools.
And where you go
depends on your zip code
or the access,
either economic or cultural,
of your family.
One of the reasons that
the public school system
has been allowed
to flounder for so long
is that it's overwhelmingly
serving low-income
black and brown kids.
We have students
in the New York City
Public School system
still today who don't
have access to computers
and technology at home,
who don't have access
to wifi at home.
The school system has not
been able to provide that,
so we at Brotherhood/Sister Sol
have provided that for
all of our young people.
So, COVID is just
accentuating all of these
existing realities
that were already here,
and you see it
in the educational system,
you see it in the labor force,
you see it in
the housing situation as well.
The non-profit sector,
which is a huge sector
in New York,
is expected to do the work
that government has abdicated.
Really,
at the end of the day,
we have to change
the entire narrative
of what is acceptable
in this country,
what true opportunity, equity,
and justice looks like.
Fabiola: It is clear
that meritocracy is a myth.
And it's a dangerous one,
because it
legitimizes inequality.
Education was supposed to be
the driving force
behind social mobility
and racial integration.
It was supposed to help us all
achieve the American dream.
But until America can give us
all an equal chance at success--
that includes
an equal starting point
and equal resources--
America can never be
a meritocracy.
As long as we define merit
according to the whims
of winners,
we'll always fall short.
What's always been missing
from the equation...
...are opportunities
and social good.
Take one, mark.
♪ There's no such thing as cold,
no such thing as cold ♪
- Oh, my God, I broke it.
- Oh, no.
- I'm sorry.
- Can we have some glue?
- You just collected.
- Lee: You just collected.
You were supposed to pay.
You just robbed the bank.